le début du conflit il c'était une
centaine d'heures au téléphone emmanuel
macron et volodymyr zelensky se
rencontrent enfin sur le perron du
palais présidentiel de kiev poignée de
main qui fera le tour du monde
quelques heures plus tôt au beau milieu
des ruines vire pin emmanuel macron
était au plus près des ravages de la
guerre en ukraine
quatre mois après l'agression russe le
chef de l'état s'est rendu dans cette
ville martyre de la banlieue de kiev
avec ses homologues italiens allemands
et room sous bonne escorte entre les
immeubles éventrés un officiel ukrainien
leur raconte des massacres qui ont eu
lieu ici longtemps
dans cette voiture il n'y avait que des
civils une famille des enfants on leur a
délibérément tiré dessus et des cas
comme ça il y en a des centaines ici
j'ai tissé rim sur un site qui a été
détruit en effet bien l'armée russe a
été arrêté à côté de plusieurs autres
villes d des massacres ont été perpétrés
ou
les premières traces parce que ce sont
des crimes de guerre objectif de cette
visite démontrer le soutien de la france
à l'ukraine et clarifier les choses une
semaine après la déclaration d' emmanuel
macron estimant qu'il ne fallait pas
humilier la russe
la france est aux côtés du crâne d'oeuf
et premiers juges et le président de
nice qui lui-même a toujours voulu
discuter avec le président poutine
aujourd'hui il faut que l'ukraine puisse
résister et l'emporter et donc nous
sommes à vos côtés de des ukrainiennes
les ukrainiens sans ambiguïté nul hier
soir vers 23 heures emmanuel macron
mario draghi olaf scholz avait embarqué
dans ce train spécial dans le sud est de
la pologne 10 heures de voyage pour
montrer la mobilisation de l'union
européenne